unser top thema heute krisentreffen in
der türkei russland und die ukraine
verhandeln finden die außenminister
einen ausweg das top thema jetzt im zdf
morgenmagazin
ja die hoffnung ist also groß kann das
treffen heute in der türkei der erste
schritt richtung frieden sein oder
zumindest richtung waffenstillstand ja
gebannt schaut die weltgemeinschaft in
die türkei wie auch gleich zuvor geht
aber der blick in die ukraine annette
streicher
nur trümmer sind übrig von dem ort an
dem bisher leben begann luftschläge
brachten gestern die erde kilometerweit
zum beben brachten tod und leid über die
geburts und kinderkliniken
eingekesselten mario pohl die opfer
wehrlose hoch schwangere mütter kinder
am späten abend findet der ukrainische
präsident worte für die grausamen bilder
europa carina bürger von mario
polarisiert er formell heute müssen wir
gemeinsam dieses kriegsverbrechen
verurteilt dass all das böse reflektiert
dass die angreifer über unser land
gebracht haben
dann erzählt er all die zerstörten
städte auf dutzende orte an denen
menschen kein zuhause keinen strom kein
trinkwasser mehr haben wie in der nähe
von mario pohl suppe aus aufgefangenen
regenwasser kochen oder im zerstörten
tief zwischen schutt nach dem nötigsten
suchen vereinbarte feuerpausen immer
wieder nicht eingehalten immerhin rund
35.000 zivilisten konnten gestern über
drei flucht korridore in sicherheit
gebracht werden
angesichts der not zeigte sich der
ukrainische präsident in interviews um
kompromisse bemüht erklärte sich bereit
zu gesprächen über einen neutralen
status der ukraine die zugehörigkeit der
krim und separatisten gebiete man habe
mögliche lösungen für knackpunkte putin
aber müsse bereit sein den dialog wieder
aufzunehmen
aus dem kreml kamen gestern die
behauptung dass russland weder eine
besetzung der ukraine noch den sturz der
aktuellen regierung wolle das hatte
schon anders geklungen kanzler scholz
hat gestern mit dem russischen
präsidenten telefoniert über
diplomatische lösungen und flucht
korridore
wie viel dialog tatsächlich möglich ist
das wird das wichtige treffen der
außenminister von russland und der
ukraine heute in der türkei zeigen die
erwartungen gedämpft zugleich werden ab
heute auf einem eu-gipfel auf schloss
west die staats- und regierungschefs
über die ukraine lage und fragen der
verteidigung und energiepolitik beraten
ein zeichen für frieden mitten im
bedrohten kiew setzten verbliebene
musiker des sinfonieorchesters die ode
an die freude auf dem majdan mit klarer
botschaft des dirigenten stoppa
[Musik]
und die andere botschaft es ist die eu
hymne schauen wir auf die verhandlungen
die heute stattfinden sollen bisher das
wissen sie gab es keine annäherung nun
bietet präsidentiellen ski einiges an
unter anderem zum beispiel einen
verzicht auf die nato mitgliedschaft und
zeigt sich auch offen die unabhängigkeit
der selbsternannten volksrepublik
johansson jetzt anzuerkennen fragen
danach bei unserer kollegin katrin
eigendorf die für uns in der west
ukraine ist kathrin noch mal einen
schönen guten morgen wie ist deine
einschätzung kann das reichen
das ist sehr schwer zu sagen also
präsident zielinski sucht nach lösungen
trotz der wirklich katastrophalen
situation die wir weiter erleben
russland bombardiert hier weiter
zivilisten
die lage im land ist wirklich dramatisch
aber der präsident hat ja klar
lösungsansätze auf den tisch gelegt ist
bereit über den über die nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine die
angestrebte zu verhandeln er ist bereit
über die unabhängigkeit und einen
sonderstatus für den don was zu
verhandeln und er ist auch bereit über
die krim zu verhandeln aber seine
verhandlungsbereitschaft die
kompromissbereitschaft kennt auch
grenzen und die liegen sicherlich darin
dass er nicht bereit ist über die
unabhängigkeit und den status der
ukraine zu verhandeln und das ist ja im
prinzip die kernfrage um dieses platini
putin hier geht er hat ja im prinzip das
ziel gehabt
die regierung hier zu entmachten
die als eine bande von faschisten
bezeichnet drogensüchtig in einem jahr
was schon gangster jargon hat er diese
regierung geschrieben hier ist
sicherlich der knackpunkt in den
verhandlungen die souveränität der
ukraine und die anerkennung einer
regierung die hier von der mehrheit der
ukrainischen bevölkerung gewählt ist das
ist das was sie lenski von putin
erwarten muss und das ist das wo ich
denke wo auch die russen den ukrainern
entgegenkommen müssen und da muss man
sehen was die verhandlungen heute
ergeben aber es ist zumindest ein
schritt in die richtige richtung das
erstmals beide staaten auf
regierungsebene miteinander verhandeln
katrin eigendorf vielen herzlichen dank
für diese einschätzung und damit gehen
wir direkt weiter an den ort wo heute
verhandelt wird jörg brase ist für uns
in antalya jörg auch die einen guten
morgen die gespräche finden im 3d format
mit dem türkischen amtskollegen stadt
die türkei nato-mitglied liefert waffen
an die ukraine wirtschaftlich ist das
land aber auch von russland abhängig
welche rolle spielt die türkei in diesem
konflikt
die türkei ist ein sehr pragmatischer
verhandlungspartner für alle seiten wie
du schon gesagt dass sie verkauft waffen
fallen drohen an die ukraine mit diesen
drohen würden werden im moment russische
truppen in der ukraine bombardiert aber
die türkei dem auch ein großes
luftabwehrsystem von russland gekauft
das hat für den hat er der nato für
große verstimmung gesorgt die türkei
verfolgt eine sehr pragmatische
außenpolitik sie arbeitet mit russland
obwohl man eigentlich in syrien krieg zb
auf unterschiedlichen seiten steht
arbeitet die türkei mit der russischen
truppen in syrien zusammenhang hat
gemeinsame position eingerichtet fährt
gemeinsame patrouillen das zeigt dass
die türkei sehr pragmatisch agiert das
ist etwas was der russische präsident
schätzt für ihn ist die türkei ein
berechenbarer verhandlungspartner das
wird grund dafür gewesen sein dass die
bemühungen präsident erdogan seines
außenministers diese
regierungsgespräche über den konflikt in
der ukraine in der türkei abschalten nun
erfolg gehabt haben man muss aber auch
sehen dass die türkei unter großem druck
steht vor allem wirtschaftlich russland
ist der größte energielieferant für die
türkei ist der größte waffenlieferant
präsident erdogan steht auch
innenpolitisch unter großem druck
wirtschaftlich es gab verhandlungen über
speisen öllieferungen durch durch
schwarze meer man merkt also dass die
türkische regierung wirklich gründe hat
zu versuchen diesen konflikt auf
diplomatischem weg zu lösen denn man ist
von russland wirtschaftlich abhängig
soweit also die einschätzung von jörg
brase werden antalya ist wo also die
beiden außenminister russlands und der
ukraine heute zusammenkommen vielen dank
dafür
und wir haben es ja gerade auch schon im
beitrag gehört also die außenminister
treffen sich auf vermittlung der türkei
am mittelmeer das ist das erste gespräch
unter regierungsvertretern beider länder
nach dem russischen angriff auf die
ukraine und damit begrüße ich jetzt den
ukrainischen botschafter in deutschland
schönen guten morgen herr melnik
guten morgen was erwarten sie heute von
diesen treffen
hauptsache das eine allumfassende
waffenruhe eingeführt wird denn bis
heute zwei wochen dauert diese perfide
barbarischen krieg vor allem gegen die
zivilisten wir haben gesehen
bilderbogen für diesen krieg gegen die
schwangeren wegen die kinder und
deswegen das wichtigste was jetzt auf
der tagesordnung steht für uns für meine
landsleute ist waffenruhe dass die
waffen schweigen das die toten geborgen
werden dass die menschen die unter den
trümmern liegen auch gerettet werden
können das ist das gebot der stunde ihr
präsident ist ganz offensichtlich zu
zugeständnissen
bereit er hat in einem interview mit dem
us fernsehsender nbc erste mögliche
zugeständnisse jedenfalls mal angedeutet
darunter sind die zum beispiel von
russland geforderte die neutralität der
ukraine im gegenzug möchte er aber
sicherheitsgarantien haben außerdem geht
es auch darum dass man sagt okay wir
gehen nicht in die nato aber wir wollen
die souveränität erhalten die
unabhängigkeit des donners auch da zeigt
sich salewski offen die große frage ist
aber was ist denn eigentlich mit der
krim sind sie bereit die krim offiziell
russland so zu schreiben
ich glaube es ist heute noch zu früh
über diese fragen zu reden und den
verhandlungen vorzugreifen main presse
denn so lenz geben hat jeden tag
bekräftigt dass er bereit ist mit herrn
putin
sich zu treffen und dass er nicht beißt
er ist bereit dieses gespräch zu führen
und leider wird aus moskau immer noch
keine antworten darauf gegeben und
solche fragen auch die die sie gerade
beschrieben haben sie können nur auf der
höchsten ebene nur in einem bilateralen
gespräch zwischen den staatsoberhäuptern
besprochen werden und deswegen was für
uns zählt unsere souveränität und
territoriale integrität sie stehen nicht
zur debatte und das bedeutet auch dass
das thema creme natürlich da gar nicht
gesprochen werden kann in dem sinn dass
wir die creme aufgeben oder das dass wir
darauf verzichten dass das die russen
quasi
diese halbinsel unsere halbinsel
annektiert haben was die neutralität
betreffe auch da ist es glaube ich noch
zu früh darüber sich gedanken zu machen
man präsident hatte angedeutet dass wir
bereit sind aber wie gesagt das war
vielleicht nur deswegen weil wir sehr
enttäuscht sind dass die nato so
zurückhaltend ist um uns zu helfen es
wurde keine deflation also keine verbote
flugzone eingeführt um die zivilisten zu
schützen es wird immer wieder
kolportiert dass die flugzeuge die
manche mitgliedstaaten und zur verfügung
stellen wollen auch da gibt es leider
kein grünes licht deswegen der
hauptsache heute für die gespräche in
die türkei
dass die waffenruhe eingeführt wird wir
sind dank bei unseren freunden in der
türkei schade dass deutschland diese
rolle jetzt aufgegeben hat sie haben der
deutschen politik
scheinheiligkeit vorgeworfen dass der
import stopp für gas öl und kohle noch
abgelehnt wird sein zitat ein messer in
den rücken der ukraine und weil olaf
scholz beim telefonat mit ihnen beim
nein zum beitritt in die eu blieb
wollten sie so heißt es jedenfalls
auflegen ist ein nein nicht aber die
wahrheit ist es nicht realistisch weil
sie so bitter das klingt die
anforderungen einfach nicht erfüllen
wir glauben dass all die strategischen
fehler die hier in deutschland begangen
wurden und ich meine jetzt die
russlandpolitik die krachend gescheitert
ist dass diese fehler mit einem einzigen
entscheidung der ampel regierung
korrigiert werden können und ich meine
gerade diese eu-weites perspektive es
geht um die zukunft meines landes es
geht darum dass die menschen die jetzt
fliehen mussten von diesen
bombenanschlägen von raketenbeschuss
dass diese menschen auch zurückkehren
können und dass das dass ihre heimat
auch zu dieser familie der eu staaten
gehören kann wir haben unsere
hausaufgaben seit 2014 gemacht und es
geht jetzt darum dass deutschland eine
führungsstärke eine führungskraft zeigt
dass deutschland wirklich jetzt
strategisch denkt und sich nicht hinter
den ausreden verstärkte wie das immer
wieder der fall war ob in bezug auf
waffenlieferungen oder auf andere themen
und es geht auch darum dass heute alles
getan wird der mit russland noch mehr
unter druck gerät damit außer beschüsse
gestopft werden dazu gehört auch ein
importstopp dafür genommen da würde ich
jetzt gerne noch mal nachhaken von
deutschland aus gibt es ja finanzhilfen
humanitäre unterstützung die lieferung
einzelner waffensysteme keine
kampfflugzeuge welche machbare
unterstützung welche realistische
unterstützung wünschen sie sich noch
ganz kurz bitter ja es gibt eine liste
von waffensystemen die wir erwarten ich
werde mich heute mit der verteidigung
treffen und ich hoffe dass wir da auch
eine ganz konkrete zusage bekommen von
dem was was wir brauchen die deutschen
wissen was benötigt wird und darum
darauf kommt es heute an herr
botschafter vielen dank für ihre zeit
und für das gespräch erneut bei uns im
zdf morgenmagazin
danke pro reli